dave outlets across the spectrum of
media are calling for chris cuomo's
firing everyone from the rolling stone
who said if any other journalist had
done this they would be fired to the new
york post editorial board who writes
cnn's decision tuesday to suspend chris
was a good first step but it needs to
issue him his permanent walking papers
no there's nothing wrong with trying to
help one sibling sibling but chris
cuomo's duty as a tv journalist was at
the least to disclose what he was doing
if not to take a leave of absence
instead he duped viewers traded on his
journalistic ties joined in attempts to
smear accusers and tilted his coverage
on camera cnn can't just wave this away
dave
well i would say first that sort of just
the obvious guttural level like does
this surprise anybody this is how
uh so much unfortunately of our news is
brought to us by people who really are
activists or are related to the people
they're reporting on in this case or
have worked for former administrations
etc etc so it's it becomes this sort of
insider game where everybody's sort of
laundering lies together you know the
idea that chris cuomo is a journalist
you know he was posing as a journalist
it's sort of like don lemon will always
tell you that he's a journalist now most
of you guys that i'm i'm proud to be
sitting here with today you tell your
opinions and it's very obvious that you
were saying hey this is what i think
about this here's some analysis these
guys will tell you that they are
journalists while they very obviously
are democrat activists so none of these
leaks seem surprising to me as this is
all sort of rolled out and i've had the
info in front of me it's like yeah of
course this is exactly what chris cuomo
was doing this is the same guy who at
the height of kovid you know as his
brother was putting all these people
back into the the old age homes you know
he was making the jokes with big q-tips
so i'm not surprised and as for what cnn
should do i mean nobody's really
watching anyway so they may as well make
a change just to see what happens and
dave i actually thought that was a
generous interpretation by the new york
post of chris cuomo's sort of liability
here essentially saying you just sort of
disclosed it but frankly the allegations
run the spectrum
he apologized in an email in
to response to his executive producer
who talked about a sexual harassment a
physical grabbing that he made of her at
a party that was literally the exact
same thing that his brother was
prosecuted for under his own laws here
in new york state which is a misdemeanor
of forcible touching so i think there's
also a wider lens focusing on chris
cuomo's behavior and his potential
liability beyond the four corners of the
television screen dave yeah well look
this is the same guy who at the height
of covet again pretended that he was
quarantined in his basement and they had
this sort of wwe style showing of him
coming out of the basement all sweaty
saying that he'd been down there and
then it turned out that actually a day
or two before that he had gotten into a
fight with a bicyclist in the hamptons i
mean it's sort of theater what they're
doing and so but that's i really mean
this you know cnn should just look at
the numbers and go well okay is this guy
delivering us numbers and the the answer
is no so if you're running a business i
don't expect cnn to be giving us
journalism but if you're just running a
business where you want to put on a
program where they put advertising on it
so you make some money you should
probably hire someone from fox i don't
know if any of you guys are looking for
a job but maybe they'll take you over
there no i'm really happy here with that
i used to be there no thank you
chris cuomo lost 80 of his viewership of
his show this year so dave's absolutely
right if they're looking for the
juggernaut to hold him in place it's
certainly not his ratings or viewership
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell